thank you very much for preparing this
opportunity to discuss about a little
bit to you Ray wearers about the World
Economic Forum this year only and my
understanding this year this forum was
more brave than previous years and they
could raise apart from parts of their
global problems if you look 23 keyboards
of this year's pamphlets of bored
Economic Forum you will find reshape
boards rethinking redesigning and
rebuilding trust this reward shows the
world is facing with entrusting facing
with the bad thinking and wrong thinking
and this is the design which is there
for the managing of the world is not
acceptable this is a part of the problem
but the second step is what is the main
routes houses of these problems we
should find out the root causes of this
problem my understanding first the
mechanism of rules and regulations which
is created not only for the economy
affairs but also for the political and
social affairs goes back to more than 60
b ches ago after the Second World War we
should reach Inc about bills mechanism
which is called burton boots mechanism
the second point is who are bringing
chew to reteach redesign and reveal
who are they are they the same team
which have created these problems are
they again the winner of the Second
World War it can't be if they we think
they will think in the same direction if
they redesign David design in the same
direction and definitely reviewing the
same building that's why we need some
new we are facing different problems in
the world today the draw problem which
is the young generation of faces sixteen
billion dollars is black money which is
coming from the population only if we
move to hurry and to the other it will
be hundreds of billions of dollars a
part of this black money goes for
terrorism but the main part goes to the
banking system to different markets what
the money laundering monitoring systems
in the board are blamed for this hundred
hundreds of billions of dollars in the
world economy I think these are good
topics for thinking thank you for your
patience e to hear